the kaiju and Jaeger content is back and
after doing the sizes of both of them we
are now showcasing you the time line of
the Pacific Rim it starts a long time
ago before humanity even started to
evolve and ends with the mega kaiju
event in Tokyo these creatures and
robots have now become very well known
amongst monster fans and it's only fair
that we do this timeline about them so
here it goes
the Triassic period in the very
beginning of the timeline it starts with
the precursors trying and ultimately
failing to colonize earth millions of
years ago in the Triassic period these
precursors are very advanced race of
colonizing aliens from the anti verse
and the creators of the kaiju August 10
2013 2 August 15 2013 this marks the
very first time in humanity had their
encounter with the monstrous kaiju as
the breach opened for a first time in
the Pacific Ocean and the kaiju named
trespasser attacking San Francisco only
to be killed by the military and using
nukes after destroying a couple of
cities February 5th 2014 after a gap of
a year and a half a second card you ship
the world and this was called hundun it
attacked Manila in the Philippines and
was also ultimately killed by a tactical
nuclear strike though it is killed its
excrement severely contaminates the
environment of the city if every eighth
2014 following these two kaiju attacks
and the fact that it was obvious it
wouldn't be the end of the kaiju attacks
on earth the kaiju emergency alert
system was established which utilized
various forms of radio and other media
June 1st 2014 this date marks skies of
emerging from the breach and its attack
hits Cabo San Lucas in Mexico the
military's attempt to lure the creature
away from a city failed and they are
forced to attack the kaiju with a
tactical nuclear strike that kills it at
expense of half the city's inhabitable
areas September 2nd 2014 after three
months another kaiju the fourth one
called seizure attacked Sydney after
three days the military lead it to an
isolated location before attempting
another
civilians were given an hour to evacuate
downtown district to escape the blast
radius and the military kills it with a
nuclear strike it is also the date that
a Yeager's were first conceived
September 15 2014 following all these
guide to attacks and emergency
international conference in Seoul South
Korea commences and a person called
Jasper Sean field
presents his idea for the Jaeger and it
was ultimately given approval by the
United Nations an unknown date in 2014
somewhere between September and November
in the fall 2014 the Pan Pacific Defense
Corps was created by the United Nations
representing 21 nation across the
Pacific Ocean
though not explicitly a Pacific adjacent
nation the United Kingdom was also
involved due to Australia and Canada
November 9 2014 the Jaeger program was
started and it was a project that
focused on the massive mobile systems
called the jaegers in response to the
kaiju threat it was funded by the Pan
Pacific Defense Corps and the United
Nations December 1st 2014 the Pan
Pacific Defense Corps proving grounds or
Jaeger testing facility is a military
reservation located on Kodiak Island it
was first used to field test and
construct the first ever fighting line
of Gyges during the kaiju war the first
series of mark 1 Yeager's including
horizon brave were constructed on the
island
January 30th 2015 this date marks the
deployment of the first ever Jaeger and
it is called brawler yukon and it is a
mark one prototype Jaeger it fought
against the kaiju called off in
Vancouver in 2015 and was the first
Jaeger constructed and deployed into
combat at the beginning of the kaiju war
April 23rd 2015 the Pacific tracking
network first spots karlof a kaiju
making its way to Vancouver with a line
of battle ready Yeager's weeks away from
the efficient deployment brawler yukon
was sent in to intercept and kill the
kaiju with a blow to the face since it
was the first ever confrontation between
a Jaeger and a kaiju the military was
also sent to assess it the 6th to the
30th December 2015 in the last month of
the year 2015 the Hong Kong shatterdome
is established
and quite a number of villegas were
commissioned into service the japanese
tacit Ronin the American Romeo blue the
Chinese horizon brave and another
Japanese Korea to tango was launched now
the world has a fleet of Yeager's to
battle the kaiju May 15 2016 this Day
marks Oni Baba's attack on the Japanese
capital city of Tokyo and was dubbed the
Oni Baba incident the Beast lays waste
to the city killing millions of people
the air force attempts to destroy the
creature only results in further demise
of the pilots involved it was ultimately
brought down by courier tango June 21st
2016 after emerging from the Tokyo Bay
attack another kaiju circus to Tokyo Bay
went acid rowland arrives from the Tokyo
shadow dome went acid ronan lands in the
bay i tag attacks doesn't roll in from
the front and manages to damage his
nuclear reactor after a while Kaori
tango appears in the fight and was also
overpowered but then attack was later
killed by tasin Ronin July 5th 2016 a
category two kaiju called Ragnarok
emerges from the breach in Tokyo Bay and
Jager victory alpha is deployed against
Ragnarok
but then victory alpha is destroyed by
Ragnarok then desert Ronan is deployed
to fight and ultimately kills the kaiju
July 10th
2017 [ __ ] danger was constructed on
Kodiak Island and the jaegers Academy's
Jaeger testing facility launched in July
10 2017 [ __ ] danger was stationed at
the Anchorage shadow dome and toss to
defend the coastline of Alaska August
22nd 2018 constructed in the province of
tchangzu China crimson typhoon was
launched on August 22nd 2018 crimson
typhoon successfully defended Hong Kong
against kaiju attacks until its
destruction in 2025 it was one of the
last old Jaeger's to be seen in the
Pacific Rim movie the winter of 2019 a
kaiju of unknown category attacks Manila
hug Hanson is deployed in Manila in
lucky seven and later gypsy DJ's also
deployed in Manila and also a third
Jaeger which is our name is - also
deployed there this was called the three
Jaeger draw
[ __ ] danger and Lucky seven kills the
kaiju in November the first Mach five
Jaeger called striker Eureka is launched
the winter of 2020 category three kaiju
knifehead emerges from the breech and
Anchorage and [ __ ] danger is deployed
from Anchorage shadow dome to defend a
Miracle Mile in the ensuing battle [ __ ]
danger initially got the upper hand but
was later severely damaged by knife ad
and one of the pilots was killed with
only one pilot in the drift [ __ ] danger
desperately and Merkley killed the kaiju
with a powerful plasma shop from October
till December 2020 for the construction
of the anti cagey wall are also called
the wall or a coastal wall was started
with the intention of preventing the
invasion of kaiju beyond the Pacific Rim
with this new construction many of the
shadow domes were shut down the military
or the Pan Pacific Defense Co tried to
put more faith on the wall rather than
the jaegers which were currently being
destroyed at an exponential rate by the
kaiju January 2025 striker Eureka is
decommissioned from active combat and
immediately after that a big and
powerful category 4 kaijus caught
mutable breaks to the anti kg wall then
Miraval was killed by striker Eureka
after it was recommissioned
after finding out that the anti kg wall
is proven ineffective against the kaiju
January 8 20 25 Newton Geisler drifts
with a kaiju brain and immediately after
that a category 4 kaijus leatherback and
also Itachi emerges from the breach and
attacks Hong Kong crimson typhoon Cherno
alpha and striking Eureka are deployed
in the battle crimson typhoon and shadow
alpha were destroyed and striker Eureka
was rendered helpless
[ __ ] danger is then deployed and
manages to kill both letter back and
Itachi
January 12 2025 category 4 kaijus Connor
and Reiji emerges from the breach first
and then a category 5 kaiju called
sladden emerges from the breach striker
Eureka and [ __ ] danger were deployed
Raju is killed by [ __ ] danger and
striker Eureka kills Connor and
Souths detonates the thermonuclear bomb
near the breach later sladden is killed
by [ __ ] danger and [ __ ] danger self
detonates himself inside the anti verse
the unknown dates in 2030 after five
years of inactivity the Jaeger program
was reinstated
during the peacetime and a lot of
progress was made regarding weapons
systems and abilities as well as
upgraded agility and a lot of Yeager's
have been constructed as well making a
huge fleet of Yeager's in case another
kaiju attack happens December 12 2013 3
till January 12 2013 these days three
very famous Yeager's were launched which
are garden Bravo the hi-tech Sabre
Athena and the resurrected [ __ ] Avenger
the namesake of [ __ ] danger 2035
scrapper was first seen in action and
was apprehended man Jake Pentecost and
his pilot Amara Nnamani are arrested by
the pan-pacific defense Co late 2035 the
events of uprising which is also called
the re-emergence of the kaiju is seen
starting with a rope Jaeger obsidian
fury attacking Sydney and then the
drones which were meant for defense
against sky to actually turn out into
hybrids and attack shadow domes and also
opened the breaches for new kaiju to
re-enter the world three kaijus emerged
and managed to enter and they become the
maker kaiju later on and was destroying
every Jaeger it could find it was later
killed by [ __ ] danger falling like a
media into it from the sky and with this
we come to the end of the timeline for
now so do subscribe and share this video
with your friends also hit that
notification bell